في لحظه من اللحظات
بصير كل همك وانت موجود داخل المعتقل ضمن
الحرمان اللي عايشه ضمن احيانا جوع جوع
طويل الامد
واذا تتذكر او مرت عليك الصور تبع قيصر
نعم
ناس يعني ممكن يكون مثلا هدول الميتين
نفسهم تبع قيصر اللي صورهم قيصر يعني ممكن
يكون صار له شهر او شهرين
يعني
جوعانين جوعانين تمام واحيانا بعضهم ممكن
يكون مات بسبب جوعة يعني
المعتقلات السوريه وخاصه في سجن تدمر يعني
بيصير المحافظه على الحياه هو الهم
الاساسي للانسان وهو الصراع على البقاء
بتصير من حيث تدري او لا تدري تهتم
باولويات حياتيه ايضا ولكن
حاله قد تحدث لاول مره لاول مره يتم فيها
جلب الطعام بعد حرمان مثلا عده ايام
ان المساجين يتصرفوا بهذه الطريقه لكن بعد
فتره
راح يكون هناك سيد الموقف يكون هناك نوع
او كم كبير من التكافل والتضامن بين
السجناء وبيصير فيه انا لم اجد يعني ايثار
وغيريه وحب الاخر
يعني هدا اكثر من
هذا الحيز المكاني اللي اسمه السجن بين
هؤلاء المعتقلين
اللي تخاطفوا اللحمه في المره الاولى
نتيجه مثلا الجوع المزمن عده ايام بعد
فتره يتعودون على سجن يتعودون على بعضهم
بصير في بين بعضهم نوع من التكافل
والتضامن
بس مش الكل لانه بالروايه طبعا ممكن
احيانا بعض الصفات الشخصيه موجوده يعني
النهائيه هناك نوع من الايثار والغيريه
داخل السجن بين السجناء بين بعضهم بعد
فتره زمنيه يعني
مانع موجوده